in the video where I give an overview of
American history through the Civil War I
commented that it's unfortunate that
Abraham Lincoln is assassinated shortly
before the end of the Civil War and
although that is technically correct
what I want to do is clarify that
comment a little bit in this video
because in actuality by the time he was
assassinated Lincoln knew that the Union
was very very very likely to win the war
that the major the major Confederate
armies had already surrendered to the
Union although it wasn't formally done
there were still some fighting going on
in some parts of the south so if we go
back to April 9th 1865 you have the
battle at Appomattox Courthouse and
after that battle the Confederate Army
is essentially routed it has to
surrender
this right here is robert e lee robert e
lee and on april 9th 1865 after that
battle he surrenders to ulysses s grant
ulysses s grant and one point of
confusion some people often have and i
had this the first time i learned it is
that a poem attics courthouse is the
name of the city that the surrender
actually did not take place in the
courthouse in that city and i actually
shouldn't even call it a city it was
like a little town of a handful of
buildings it took place in this
gentleman's house Wilmer McLean and I'm
showing his image because his his set of
circumstances or how he is tied to the
Civil War is frankly fascinating because
in 1861 the first battle of the Civil
War occurred on his property in Manassas
Virginia this is in northern virginia he
was sympathetic with the confederate
army he did not like that northern
virginia was so close to the the
north-south border so he picks up his
bags and his family and he moves them
down to the small town of Appomattox
Courthouse which is in central Virginia
so the very first major land battle of
the Civil War
literally occurs on this guy's property
and the vet and the last major or the
the the really the major surrender of
the city
war occurs inside this guy's house after
he moves and it's all coincidence he
just happened to have the nicest house
near the battlefield where everyone felt
that it was appropriate to have this
kind of major end to a major war but
regardless that happens on April 9th
1865 the major Confederate Army
surrenders to the Union Army the reason
why this is not the formal end of the
Civil War is that you still had 175,000
Confederate troops other places in the
south continuing to fight on you have to
remember that we didn't have a telephone
at this point in time so we didn't have
instant communication so these people
who are fighting many of them did not
even know that the that the Confederate
Army had already surrendered to the
Union but to some degree this major
surrender is what leads to Lincoln's
assassination because this was you know
for most people this is this tells you
hey there's a 99.9% chance that the
Union has won it just has to either
these people need to find out that their
major army has surrendered or the Union
has to go and essentially force these
all of the rest of the armies to
surrender so you go to April 14 1865
Lincoln already knows that robert e
lee's army has surrendered he knows that
victory is imminent but you have this
gentleman right over here John Wilkes
Booth John John Wilkes Booth who is
sympathetic to the Confederate cause and
in his mind all is not lost yet he does
see this as a major blow to the
Confederate cause and he thinks that
they need to do something desperate if
they want to have any chance of being
able to come back being able to maintain
their independence from the Union so he
coordinates with a couple of his buddies
and he says hey our only chance is if we
assassinate not only Abraham Lincoln but
also Andrew Johnson who's the vice
president and ulysses s grant and
ulysses s grant and we assassinate
seward who is the Secretary of State and
the idea
if you assassinate everyone who was in
line to become president that it would
just throw the entire union leadership
in disarray and maybe it would give
these characters over here fighting
chance to maintain their independence or
maybe come back against the Union Army
unfortunately for John Wilkes Booth or I
guess he well you could you could take
it either way the other three people
were not able to fully execute on their
plan Seward was injured the he actually
did get stabbed in the face and all that
but he was not assassinated and John
Wilkes Booth was the only person who was
able to carry out his assassination so
you have on April 14 1865 shortly after
10:00 p.m. Abraham Lincoln is watching a
play at Ford's Theatre and his booth the
guy who was supposed to guard the booth
was out drinking with his buddy so I
guess the Secret Service really you know
the the security was not back then what
it is now hopefully what it is now and
John Wilkes Booth who actually used to
act at this theater who he picked a time
in the play where everyone would laugh
and clap and he said hey I'll just shoot
right then people would think it's part
of the play or something or they
wouldn't notice as much and then I'll be
able to run out and so he is able to
write at that moment shortly after 10:00
p.m. shoot Abraham Lincoln and
assassinate him on April 14th 1865 but
the whole point here is to just
understand that Lincoln did know that
that that robert e lee's army had
assassinated had had surrendered at the
time of his assassination so he at least
was feeling pretty good about the course
of the war